اسمي Jessica Nelson roll ، أنا
عضو في جمعية 61 - soundness Society
هنا في مينيابوليس ، هذه واحدة من
عدد قليل من حمامات الساونا المتنقلة التي نمتلكها في
المنطقة لأول مرة ، شعرت
وكأنني انتهيت للتو من جلسة تدليك لمدة 90 دقيقة
في  جزء بسيط من سعر التدليك ، يكون
تأثير الصوت على جسمك
مشابهًا للتمارين الرياضية ، فهو يزيد من
معدل ضربات القلب ويزيد من تدفق الدم ،
ولكنه أيضًا تجربة مريحة للغاية ، وقد
ثبت طبياً أن له
فوائد لصحة القلب والأوعية الدموية ،
لذا يمكن أن يقلل  خطر إصابتك بالنوبات
القلبية والسكتات الدماغية على وجه التحديد مرة واحدة
في الجلسة ، لذا فإن حوالي 30 دقيقة من الصوت
عند الاستحمام يمكن أن تقلل من ضغط الدم
بحوالي خمس إلى عشر نقاط ،
وهناك بعض الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
أمراض القلب يجب أن يسألوا طبيبهم
قبل السبر ولكن تحدث
الساونا بشكل عام  يمكن أن تكون الحياة الآمنة مرهقة للغاية
والشيء الوحيد الذي أعرفه هو أنه يمكنني
الذهاب إلى الغرفة الحارة ، ثم يخرج العرق
ثم أشعر وكأنني شخص جديد عندما
انتهيت